- I was with the homies chillin'—and I don't know the rest.
- Me neither.
[Laughing]
- What's up, everybody? It's your boy, Lance Fresh
and welcome to Finish the Lyric, where we
pair athletes with some of their favorite artists.
Today's guest? My guys YG and Todd Gurley.
We're gonna test Todd on his knowledge of YG's music.
- [Laughing]
- I don't know.
- Then we're gonna even the playing field, and we're gonna go to
some classic songs, some popular songs.
And we're gonna test both of you guys.
And then we're gonna chop it up
and then we're gonna get to know you guys better.
- If the NFL generating the same or more
then they players should be getting the same or more
—you feel what I'm sayin'?
That's just me being a hunnid.
- Finally, we're gonna shoot a music video, where you're gonna switch roles
and you're gonna be the star
and you're gonna be the hype man.
♪♪♪
You ready?
- Yeah.
- Let's get it.
Fellas, fellas. Todd, can you hear me?
- Yeah.
- So, uh, now it's time to test your knowledge of YG's music.
The first song is "Bicken Back Being Bool."
- [Laughing]
- Ahh, hold on.
Hold on. Start me over.
I remember. Start me over. Start me over. Start me over.
- So now it's time to chop it up.
You know, I'm gonna pull a card from the deck.
I'm gonna read it
and then we’re gonna go around and we’re gonna answer these questions.
Ready?
So first question, for Todd.
What do you remember the first time
about the first time you started listening to YG?
- It was in high school, probably like 11th grade
and just used to always kinda listen to him.
And then my homeboys are just like
"Man, we just about to start calling you TG4hunnid.”
- Yeahhh.
- And that's when I kinda made, I made my Instagram.
That's what all my teammates used to start calling me
college, high school, NFL
- We can pop to the next question.
You can get that one, Todd.
- Me?
- Yeah
- YG: What about Todd Gurley has made you a big fan?
- First thing first: It was, like, some years ago
I was on tour, like, probably, like, two thousand, like, 13, 14.
And one of your boys, he came to the show
and he seen one of my people and was
like, “I gotta get—I gotta go talk to YG.
You feel me? The homie, Todd Gurley, you feel me.”
He f--k with him heavy.
So that’s when I hopped on the phone with bruh back in the day.
You feel me? I’m like, “Yeah.”
We was just choppin’ it up. He like
“I f--k with you.” I’m like, “Good lookin’,” you know what I’m sayin’?
And then he said he went to the Rams and s--t
then the Rams came to L.A., and I’m like, “Oh, this s--t is crazy.”
[Laughing]
I’m like, “This s--t is crazy,” but that’s No. 1.
You feel me? I support people that support me.
All day, to the fullest.
And then bro nice, though, like, so it’s like, he nice regardless.
And we neighbors and s--t. It’s all types of crazy.
- [Laughing] Yeah. That s--t’s funny.
That s--t—that s--t’s crazy.
- It’s just crazy, bro, but uh, man
it’s love, you know what I’m sayin’, bro? It’s savage.
I’m inspired by football. I go to the games
and be inspired to go do what I do after that
with all my business stuff and music and s--t like that.
♪♪♪
- Todd, you said you want me to start over?
- Yeah, start me over.
All right. We’re gonna, we’re gonna give you one more chance.
—and I don’t know the rest.
- Me neither, n---a.
[Laughing]
I’m tryna remember that s--t.
- Hey, YG. So how’d he do on that one?
- Ohh, man. He got like 25 percent.
[Laughing]
♪♪♪
How do you feel about players in the NFL kneeling?
Y'all hittin’ some poli—politics, bro.
- I mean, I mean, you’ve been
—you’ve been a part of that whole movement, I mean.
- Uh, all right. I’mma keep it real. Once again.
I was talking to Kaepernick about this.
Um
like, when they started kneeling
at the time there was a lot of black people
was getting killed by the police
it was just a lot of crazy s--t going on.
It’s still goin’ on, but it was just crazy at the time.
When they was kneeling, that’s what the kneel was about.
And the people—I don’t know if it was the NFL or just the people in the world
they was tryna make it about the military and all this
and it’s like, “Bro, we, we ain’t talkin’ ‘bout the military.”
I’m from the streets, bro. I respect the military.
I respect everybody that go to the military that’s
willing to sacrifice they life for the country they from.
Just to see how they tried to turn it—and it’s just crazy
it’s like, “Bro, we talkin’ about something else.”
- Whole different subject.
- Yeah, whole different—it’s like
“Bro, our people gettin’ killed, bro.”
- You were a part of that, uh, that whole
you know, them taking his name off of your song.
What was like—how’d you feel about that?
- I didn’t know nothin’ about it. I didn’t agree to it.
I didn’t know nothin’, so I just felt like it was like, uhh
it was shady cuz
it put me in a situation with somebody that I’m cool with and support.
Been supportive from before he had this goin’ on.
It just made us look crazy
cuz when I found out about it
they had found out about it.
I woke up, you feel me—they hit me like
“Hey, bro, you know they took my name out your song, man?”
I’m like, “What?” Like, “Hold on. I ain’t got nothin’ to do with it, bro.”
[Laughing]
Like, you know what I’m saying?
So it just put me in a weird situation.
But when I talked to him, he’s like
“Bro, I know you ain’t got nothin’ to do with it.”
I’m like, “All right, fasho. But, uh, we gonna figure it out.”
♪♪♪
- All right, y’all. The next song: “Twist my Fingaz.”
YG, you’re gonna start it off
and Todd’s gonna finish the lyric.
[Laughing]
I don’t know.
- Wear my socks like a cholo.
- All right. We’re gonna give him another chance. And we’re gonna start
with YG first.
♪♪♪
- Ayy
Ayy
♪♪♪
- When you see NBA players receive guaranteed contracts
how does that make you feel?
Uh, how do that make me feel?
It make me feel good, man.
Just seeing another player, first of all—anybody, I don’t care.
Especially, you know, a black player, you know, get that payday.
Cuz we always in the same shoes, so.
- Y’all want my honest—
[Laughing]
You all want me to be honest, bro?
- Yeah
- Man. Um, I mean
from what I’ve been hearing, like
the NFL makes more money than the NBA.
- Oh, way more.
- So if the NFL’s generating the same or more
then the players should be getting the same
or more—you feel what I’m sayin’?
That’s just me being a hunnid.
- So this is to YG
So you’ve been on the record saying that the NBA is soft.
Do you think that LeBron James could play for the Los Angeles Rams?
- You said the Los Angeles Rams?
- Yeah.
- Well, you said I said the NBA was soft?
- When I say that?
- Uh, like last year.
- Around them boys flopping.
- Yeah, maybe, maybe it was around flopping.
- [Laughing]
I don’t know, bro. I don’t remember that
but LeBron look like he could be a tight end or something.
A receiver.
- We could definitely use LeBron. We could definitely use LeBron.
- Yeah, he like—how tall is bro, like 6’8” or something?
- Yeah
[Laughing]
- Would you take him on the team?
- Oh yeah. Yeah. We’d put him right there at receiver, tight end.
Fade ball, all the time in the red zone.
- In the NBA, a lot of guys are flopping
complaining about fouls, whereas in football, like, you get hit.
- You feel me.
- Nah, we’re getting soft too.
NFL getting soft with all those rules.
- I feel like it’s gettin’ soft but at the same time
I understand why. Cuz of the s--t these football players
some of them, be goin’ through at, like, later on in they life.
You know what I’m sayin’?
And it’s like, that s--t real.
You still gotta be a tough motherf--ker to be on the field playing football
cuz it’s just consistent contact. You know what I’m sayin’?
- Like our era, s--t. Growing up we used to—with the Ray Lewis
you know what I’m sayin’?
Yeah
- Patrick Willis. Troy Polamalu. Ed Reed.
Everybody gettin’ their head smacked off.
I mean, obviously, you know
you wanna protect the players, but—
- [Laughing]
- That’s just what—that’s just what we seen growing up
you know what I’m saying? That’s just the game we know.
We’re not out here playin’ flag football.
♪♪♪
- All right. Now this time, we’re gonna put both of you
guys on the hot seat. Rick Ross, “Hustlin’.”
Let’s go.
- All right, y’all. Who we think won that? Who won that one?
- We 50-50, bro.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That first verse is classic.
- The first verse, know that one, yeah.
Everybody know the first verse.
♪♪♪
- Any, uh, any questions you guys have for
each other that you always wanted to ask or—?
- Oh, I got a question. Oh God, I was gonna ask this earlier.
[Laughing]
Hey, look. Like, when you all as a team, players period
when you all get, like, motherf--kers—another motherf--ker
that’s a rapper or famous or whatever, successful
- and they pull up to the games and they be doin’ whatever they doin’
you feel me, they be on they support s--t, how y’all feel about that?
Do you be like, “Aw, that s--t fake.”
Like, “Oh, we ain’t f--king with y’all” or what?
[Laughing]
- Nah, nah. That’s funny, though. That’s funny.
- That’s a real question, bro.
- So we just like—we just be joking all the time.
Everybody like, you know, “YG at the game"
you know, we, we’s on the sideline.
My n---a like, “Damn, n---a, this n---a like
the new ‘Pac around this b---h.”
- [Laughing]
- And then another n---a come like
“Man, what this b---h-ass n---a doin’ here, man?”
- [Laughing]
- So we—
- You’re like, “Who? Who’s this?”
[Laughing]
- So—but nah, it goes both ways, though, like
I mean—
We always—we always gonna say that stuff
we always gonna talk our stuff but you know
we appreciate everybody that do come to the game.
♪♪♪
- So we did Finish the Lyric, we chopped it up
and now it’s time for you to shoot your music video.
You ready?
- Yeah.
- Any pointers for him? This is his first music video.
- Vibe out, bro. That’s it.
- All right. Let’s get it. DJ!
My b---h drive a all-white Range
Couldn't hit it if you n---as had aim
Lames can't call and you lame
You had it, then you lost it, Hall of Shame
I can buy a Bentley, don't talk to me
For a show 150, don't talk to me
You ain't never helped your mans, don't talk to me
You just follow all the trends, don't talk to me
Ay, I set the bar, I'm the f--kin' bar
Look in the sky, I'm a f--kin' star
I don't fall in love cuz I be lovin' hard
Do everything like my shirt, extra large
I don't care how I crash a Ghost
Got two cribs in two states, I be doin’ the most
I got white-folks money that I won't blow
And if you ask why, cuz the white folks don't
Big bank take lil' bank, bank
♪♪♪
- Hey, you killed it. How you feelin’?
- I’m good, man. I’m good.
- How’d he do?
- Aww, man. We lit, bro. Whatchu talkin’ about?
- We out here. So, uh, thanks for watching.
This is your boy, Lance Fresh. Finish the Lyric. YG. Todd Gurley. We are out.
- Yeahhh.